the question is just how many dollars
are gonna have left once the dust
settles on this because it's still a
significant commitment to jj watt in a
year when the caps going down that's the
other side of it the caps going down jj
white got 15.5 million over two years oh
and by the way they still have kyler
murray on a rookie deal now is the time
to splurge if you're going to splurge
because at some point you're going to
have to pay kyler murray so much money
it's going to be harder to splurge yeah
yeah i mean you're right and you know
listen j.j watt he is j.j watt he does
have value on the field you know he's a
polarizing figure you know as far as
people are going to buy jerseys that's
99 arizona cardinals they're going to do
if it's 99. if there's 99 available
you're right i'm that
it's been retired it's oh sorry marshall
goldberg so he's an actor reading pft
okay nah i didn't read that one uh but
yeah so
so there is that aspect of it certainly
but i i will say i'm still
you know
shocked by the price tag a little bit
i'm not going to lie i mean again i if i
were a gm i don't know if i could have
thrown that kind of money out at jj watt
and i don't mean that to be
disrespectful to j.j watt but i know
it's what it's missed maybe 32 out of
the last 80 games
it's 26 and a half sacks over the last
five years and something i talked about
in my podcast a little yesterday mike is
i mean if you look at other players that
are comparable to that like i look at a
guy like calais campbell who has a kind
of the same
type of position jj watt is versatile
can play defensive tackle can play
defense n can do them both you know he's
been hurt a lot less
and has much more sack production uh
than jjy and he's making 12 million
dollars a year so i think that's where i
was surprised by the price tag overall
but i will say this too
you know we see like the last two years
it's nine sacks total right and i know
he missed eight games in in 2019. one
thing you have to take into account
with the sax always right we know that
it can be an overrated stat and we like
the uh f the play up right that really
tells you more about him and he's pretty
damn good at effing plays up still
you got to remember too with the houston
texans
i mean
geez
you the last few years you might have
been able to go out there and throw for
50 an nfl game against that secondary so
quarterbacks didn't have to hold the
ball a whole lot or real long against
the houston texans the last few years
too so you have to take that aspect you
know i think into the the totality of
what he is at this point too and i'm
excited to see him in red and see what
he can do
it's it's a projection right definitely
a projection it's a leap of faith and
and i still
refuse
to accept as 100 truthful the reports on
the numbers i've seen this sausage get
made enough times you know the saying
the truth or i sh i i screwed it up
before i even got it out
the sausage is already messed up nobody
cares yeah i almost i almost i almost
you know what i almost i almost said
something i shouldn't have said after i
realized o'clock in england a lie a lie
gets halfway around the world before the
truth gets its pants on that's what i
was trying to say when it comes to these
nfl contracts
the the the lie does the full
traversing of the globe
but and the truth never gets
acknowledged that's what happens so
you know these numbers if and and the
smart agents know how to keep these
numbers under wraps for a few days so by
the time they come out everybody's moved
on to something else nobody cares
anymore it's just the way it works yeah
but i i'm gonna be very curious to see
the structure the true guarantee and is
it really is it really
two years 31 million or is it
and i'm not i don't know this but i've
seen this before this is why i'm
skeptical is it two years 26 million
with five million in
usually reachable incentives or or per
game roster bonuses which i would want
in there
protect myself if he can't play 500 000
a year in per game roster bonuses little
things like that chip it down into
something that isn't between 15 and 16
million there's a lot of lying that goes
on in this business and one of the
things we try to do which makes me even
more unpopular than otherwise would be
we try to smoke it out and let people
know the truth it just bothers me when
bs gets thrown around and reporters just
who want to fill a quote and impress
their bosses will just pass along
whatever bs lands in their lap without
scrutiny that bugs me so we'll see we'll
see if the bs that got passed around
yesterday is true bs or fake bs yeah
you're right uh we we will see and uh
you know i i had the same thoughts as
you as well was it you know really okay
23 guaranteed with a little bit more on
top of that and then you're right you
got to do something on the field or stay
healthy to get the rest of it either way
it's a big time move for him i wasn't
expecting to hear arizona cardinals
that's the one thing i'll say i i really
was not i really thought really at the
end of the day
we were going to hear
tennessee titans or green bay packers
that to me was what i was expecting to
hear i thought maybe he'd go back with
vrabel and look at that team and go ooh
they're pretty close or he'd go hey i
grew up in wisconsin and just about
every kid wants to go home and and play
for the green bay packers when you grow
up in wisconsin and they got aaron
rodgers uh i really expected it to be
one of those two so i was shocked when i
saw that news come across
plays the packers this year wow plays
the titans this year plays the texans
this year
goes back to texas this year against the
cowboys and
if the 17th game formula and approach
that peter king laid out yesterday in
football morning in america holds
cardinals at browns this year another
team that was closely linked to jj watts
so oh oh and then there's the two games
against the rams seahawks and 49ers as
well the cardinals games got a lot
sexier with the presence of jj watt and
as the nfl moves toward
announcing the schedule which will be
here before we know it mid to late april
before the draft that's how they usually
do it they made an exception last year
because of the pandemic but whenever we
get that schedule those cardinals games
a lot more enticing definitely than they
were before j.j watt
joined the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports